Wariacyjny kwantowy solver własny, czyli VQE, to jeden z najwcześniejszych hybrydowych algorytmów kwantowo-klasycznych i jest
interesujący z kilku powodów. Po pierwsze, jak zobaczymy w tym filmie, to obiecujące podejście do pewnych typów problemów. Po drugie, jest ważny
historycznie i utorował drogę wielu udoskonalonym algorytmom, takim jak adapt VQE.
I wreszcie VQE jest dość prosty. Łatwo zrozumieć, co robią komputer kwantowy i klasyczny w tym algorytmie
i jak ze sobą współdziałają. VQE składa się z czterech głównych elementów.
Po pierwsze, jest operator, często Hamiltonian, który nazwiemy H, opisujący właściwość układu, którą
chcesz zoptymalizować. Inaczej mówiąc, szukasz wektora własnego tego operatora, który
odpowiada minimalnej wartości własnej. Taki wektor własny często nazywamy stanem podstawowym.
Następnie mamy ansatz – słowo oznaczające podejście. To quantum circuit, który przygotowuje stan kwantowy przybliżający
szukany wektor własny. Właściwie ansatz to rodzina quantum circuits, ponieważ niektóre gates w
ansatzu są sparametryzowane. To znaczy, że podajemy im parametr, który możemy zmieniać. Ta rodzina quantum circuits
może przygotować rodzinę stanów kwantowych przybliżających stan podstawowy.
Następnie potrzebujemy estymatora – sposobu szacowania wartości oczekiwanej operatora H dla aktualnego wariacyjnego
stanu kwantowego. Czasem interesuje nas po prostu ta wartość oczekiwana, którą
nazywamy funkcją kosztu. Innym razem zależy nam na bardziej skomplikowanej funkcji, którą nadal można wyrazić zaczynając od
jednej lub więcej wartości oczekiwanych.
Na koniec potrzebujemy klasycznego optymalizatora – algorytmu, który zmienia parametry, próbując zminimalizować tę funkcję kosztu.
Zanim omówimy rolę obliczeń kwantowych, zarysujmy problem i ogólne podejście. Wiele
problemów optymalizacyjnych kluczowych dla nauki i przemysłu można sformułować jako problemy macierzowe. Zazwyczaj chcesz
znaleźć minimalną wartość własną macierzy i odpowiadający jej wektor własny. Macierz H może być
Hamiltonianem opisującym energię układu fizycznego. Wtedy minimalna wartość własna to energia stanu podstawowego
E0, a wektor własny to odpowiadający kwantowy stan podstawowy, często oznaczany ψ₀.
Albo macierz może opisywać skomplikowaną funkcję kosztu związaną z problemami optymalizacji kombinatorycznej,
na przykład w logistyce, a wektor własny s_opt byłby optymalnym rozwiązaniem
problemu, jak binarny ciąg etykietujący cięcie w grafie sieci dystrybucji. W praktyce
termin Hamiltonian bywa używany dla wszystkich macierzy będących przedmiotem zainteresowania, nawet poza naukami ścisłymi. Powiedzmy,
że interesuje nas macierz o n wierszach i n kolumnach. Takie problemy można rozwiązać szybko i dokładnie klasycznymi
solverami dla n do kilkuset lub kilku tysięcy, bez żadnych założeń o macierzy. Dla macierzy rzadkich,
czyli takich z przewagą zer, n może być znacznie większe – nawet miliard na laptopie.
Ale dla naprawdę ogromnych problemów przekraczających te liczby często potrzebne są metody przybliżone lub heurystyczne.
Im większa macierz i mniej rzadka, tym problem trudniejszy i tym więcej sprytnych trików trzeba zastosować. Załóżmy, że macierz jest tak
duża, że dokładna diagonalizacja nie wchodzi w grę. Załóżmy dalej, że wystarczająco dobrze znasz problem, żeby
zrobić pewne założenia co do ogólnej struktury stanu docelowego i chcesz badać stany podobne do swojego
wstępnego przybliżenia, by sprawdzić, czy możesz jeszcze obniżyć koszt lub energię. To jest podejście wariacyjne i jedna z metod
stosowanych, gdy dokładna diagonalizacja nie jest możliwa przy użyciu komputera klasycznego. Działałoby to tak.
Po pierwsze, tworzysz stan-zgadywankę z pewnym parametrem theta, który będziesz zmieniać.
Choć ten wstępny wybór mógłby być losowy, nie jest to zalecane. Chcemy wykorzystać wiedzę o problemie,
żeby jak najlepiej dostosować nasze przybliżenie.
Po drugie, obliczamy wartość oczekiwaną operatora przy układzie w tym stanie.
Po trzecie, zmieniamy parametry wariacyjne i powtarzamy.
Po czwarte, wykorzystujemy zgromadzone informacje o krajobrazie możliwych stanów w podprzestrzeni wariacyjnej, by formułować coraz lepsze
przybliżenia i zbliżać się do stanu docelowego.
Zasada wariacyjna gwarantuje, że nasz stan wariacyjny nie może dać wartości własnej niższej niż ta
docelowego stanu podstawowego. Im niższa wartość oczekiwana, tym lepsze przybliżenie stanu podstawowego. Omówmy
trudność każdego kroku w tym podejściu.
Ustawianie lub aktualizacja parametrów jest obliczeniowo łatwa. Trudność polega tu na wyborze użytecznych,
fizycznie umotywowanych parametrów początkowych. Aktualizacja parametrów z wykorzystaniem zgromadzonych informacji z poprzednich iteracji
w taki sposób, by zbliżyć się do stanu podstawowego, jest nietrywialnym zadaniem. Istnieją jednak klasyczne algorytmy optymalizacji, które robią to
całkiem sprawnie. Ta klasyczna optymalizacja jest kosztowna tylko dlatego, że może wymagać wielu
iteracji. W najgorszym przypadku liczba iteracji może rosnąć wykładniczo z n.
Obliczeniowo najkosztowniejszym pojedynczym krokiem jest niemal na pewno obliczenie wartości oczekiwanej macierzy dla
danego stanu. Macierz n×n musi działać na wektor o n elementach, co odpowiada rzędowi n do kwadratu
operacji mnożenia w najgorszym przypadku. To musi być wykonywane przy każdej iteracji parametrów. Dla bardzo
dużych macierzy ma to wysoki koszt obliczeniowy. Teraz wyobraź sobie, że przenosisz tę część obliczeń
na komputer kwantowy. Zamiast obliczać tę wartość oczekiwaną, szacujesz ją, przygotowując
stan s(theta) na komputerze kwantowym przy użyciu wariacyjnego ansatzu, a następnie wykonując pomiary.
Przyjrzyjmy się temu bliżej. H zazwyczaj nie jest łatwy do zmierzenia. Może być na przykład złożony z wielu
niekomutujących operatorów Pauliego X, Y i Z.
Ale H można zapisać jako liniową kombinację składników H_α, z których każdy jest łatwy do zmierzenia. Na przykład
operatorów Pauliego lub grup bitowo komutujących operatorów Pauliego.
Wartość oczekiwana H dla stanu S jest ważoną sumą wartości oczekiwanych składowych H_α.
WEBVTT
To wyrażenie zachodzi dla każdego stanu s, ale będziemy go używać konkretnie z naszym wariacyjnym stanem s(theta).
Każdy ze składników h_α można zmierzyć m razy, uzyskując próbki pomiarowe s_ dla j od
1 do m, co daje wartość oczekiwaną i odchylenie standardowe. Możemy
sumować te składniki i propagować błędy przez sumę.
Nie wymaga to mnożenia na dużą skalę ani żadnego procesu skalującego jak n do kwadratu. Zamiast tego
potrzeba wielu pomiarów na komputerze kwantowym. Jeśli nie potrzebujesz ich zbyt wielu, to podejście może być
efektywne. I na tym polega kwantowa część VQE. Ale porozmawiajmy o powodach, dla których może ono nie być efektywne. Jednym z powodów
dużej liczby pomiarów jest zmniejszenie niepewności statystycznej w szacunkach dla bardzo precyzyjnych
obliczeń. Innym powodem jest liczba ciągów Pauliego potrzebnych do opisania całej macierzy. Ponieważ macierze Pauliego plus
identyczność rozpinają przestrzeń wszystkich operatorów danego wymiaru, mamy gwarancję,
że możemy zapisać naszą macierz jako ważoną sumę operatorów Pauliego, jak wcześniej. Tu C_α to
współczynnik numeryczny, a H_α to ciąg operatorów Pauliego działających na wszystkie qubity opisujące układ.
H_α miałby taką postać, gdzie n-ty operator Pauliego od prawej działa na n-ty qubit. Możemy więc
mierzyć nasz operator, mierząc serię operatorów Pauliego. Nie możemy jednak mierzyć wszystkich tych operatorów Pauliego
jednocześnie. Operatory Pauliego z wyłączeniem identyczności nie komutują ze sobą, jeśli są
przypisane do tego samego qubitu. Na przykład możemy mierzyć I Z IIZ i ZZ
jednocześnie, bo możemy mierzyć I i Z jednocześnie dla trzeciego
qubitu. I możemy znać I i X jednocześnie dla pierwszego qubitu. Ale nie możemy
mierzyć wszystkich Z i ZZ ZX jednocześnie, bo Z i X nie
komutują i oba działają na zerowy qubit.
Rozkładamy więc naszą macierz H na sumę Paulich działających na różne qubity.
Niektóre składniki tej sumy można zmierzyć jednocześnie. Nazywamy to grupą komutujących Paulich. W zależności od
liczby niekomutujących składników możemy potrzebować wielu takich grup. Nazwijmy liczbę takich grup komutujących
Paulich t.
Jeśli ngcp jest małe, to może działać dobrze.
Jeśli h ma miliony grup, to nie będzie użyteczne. Rejestrujesz wartość oczekiwaną lub funkcję kosztu
dla zestawu parametrów theta użytych w stanie, a następnie aktualizujesz parametry w czasie. Możesz używać
wartości oczekiwanych lub wartości funkcji kosztu do przybliżenia gradientu funkcji kosztu w
podprzestrzeni stanów próbkowanych przez twój ansatz.
Istnieją zarówno gradientowe, jak i bezgradientowe klasyczne optymalizatory. Oba cierpią na potencjalne problemy z wyuczalnością, takie jak
wiele minimów lokalnych i duże obszary przestrzeni parametrów z niemal zerowym gradientem, zwane barren plateaus.
Czy VQE rozwiąże wszystkie twoje najtrudniejsze problemy? Nie. Ale bycie lepszym we wszystkich obliczeniach nigdy nie było celem. Zmieniliśmy
to, co determinuje koszt obliczeniowy. Popatrz, co zamieniliśmy. Przeszliśmy od procesu,
którego złożoność zależy tylko od wymiaru macierzy, do takiego, który zależy od wymaganej precyzji i liczby
niekomutujących operatorów Pauliego tworzących macierz. Ten ostatni element nie ma odpowiednika w obliczeniach klasycznych.
Na podstawie tych nowych zależności, dla macierzy rzadkich lub macierzy zawierających niewiele niekomutujących ciągów Pauliego,
ten proces może być użyteczny. Tak jest w przypadku układów oddziałujących spinów. Dla macierzy gęstych może być
mniej użyteczny. Wiemy na przykład, że układy chemiczne często mają Hamiltoniany zawierające setki, tysiące, a nawet
miliony ciągów Pauliego. Prowadzono interesujące prace nad redukcją liczby tych składników, ale
układy chemiczne mogą być lepiej dostosowane do innych algorytmów, które omówimy na tym kursie.
Skuteczne użycie VQE wymaga też znajomości cech stanu docelowego i doboru odpowiedniego, fizycznie
umotywowanego stanu początkowego oraz dobrego ansatzu z relatywnie niewielką liczbą parametrów wariacyjnych. Może to być
dość trudne. VQE pokazuje, jak można łączyć mocne strony komputerów klasycznych i kwantowych
bez stosowania nowszych metod. VQE nie pomaga nam rozwiązywać problemów nierozwiązywalnych dla komputerów klasycznych, ale
nadal odgrywa rolę w rozwijaniu algorytmów. VQE uczy nas też, że przeniesienie kroku z komputera klasycznego
na kwantowy nie jest ani lepsze, ani gorsze dla wszystkich celów. Raczej
zmienia czynniki decydujące o efektywności algorytmu. To ważna ogólna lekcja o hybrydowym
obliczaniu kwantowo-klasycznym.